just keep it going here's Tom Brady's
new girlfriend holy God guacamole she
has an NBA and a Masters of Science
511 also Jewish those tits are 19 pounds
[__] okay ow that's somebody's
girlfriend that's literally the new
mother
oh my God damn what is happening
damn come on out y'all not see what I'm
seeing that's funny you know I think
it's just a rebound you know you're not
taking it I think it's just surprising
coming from you I expected it here and I
got it I wasn't ready
I don't think they're a real thing I
think she's using it
what specifically I think the
relationship is real ah I don't think
they're actually doing anything why are
people speculating about it he's been
saying I'm in love with him for like
weeks or months or whatever she like has
this whole thing it's like a whole bit
and there's no like actual I don't see
any pictures of them together she just
keeps playing it up I'll just gossiping
I think everybody
I don't know maybe you know because I
actually I from what I understand when I
looked it up I didn't see any pictures
of them together yeah and she this is
like a [__] she loves Tom Brady she
grew up loving Tom Brady Etc and then
she said something like have a big
reveal coming this Sunday but that I
don't think I think that's why people
think you think Leo's girl grew up
loving Leo
yes no Titanic might have been before
time yeah yeah
Titanic was for sure before we talked
about Leonardo DiCaprio's incredible
taste and young [__]
just discussed is impeccable
um rookie signings listen
this man's ability this man's ability to
see
I mean
I'm trying to think of somebody that has
had this much success like the Warriors
yeah the worst yeah yeah maybe the
Warriors yeah Bill Belichick like who is
who's Nick Saban because he gets him out
of high school and they're just ready
Joe Jackson he's pretty good well Joe
Jackson was good also but they were his
own yeah um this right here he's Nick
Saban I mean like nobody has scouted
High School talent yeah the way that
Leonardo Dicaprio and recruiting he
recruits I mean like that guy's a
recruiter you know I mean they're ready
the guy
five stars you know what I mean
literally every recruit coming back to
back
like you said in back or on back both
okay [__]
is that a blue check you think if you
meet a girl and you're like oh this is
Leo's ex yes does it automatically raise
her stock yes you just wait a few years
you know what I mean is it qualified
you're saying if she got her [__]
smushed by Leonardo DiCaprio exactly
there's a lot of weird dudes out here
no blue check like is a quality you're
verified Oh I thought it meant that it
would increase in value forever you're
so white right now
that you made that a stock reference
dude
I'm The Wolf of Wall Street dude oh we
know yeah
[Laughter]
we've seen you in that full moon come
out my boy that full moon come out of
ears
he started getting hungry
he's not getting real hungry
can we get back to you yes let's just be
serious can we just be serious yeah
let's just do feelings so fast let's
just go through a bunch of stories and
just tell me how you feel without any
facts okay I want to talk about I want
to talk about them Chopstick balloons it
was flying over the United States of
America yeah come on bro yes the Chinese
Lantern Festival can we talk about the
Genesis let's talk about it
she's Korean
oh [__] come on son my back come on what
side is that that's North bro you Gotta
Throw the answer